welcome back to episode 4 of this
beginner c++ series hope you're all
learning a lot it's probably gonna take
a while for these videos to actually get
views so I'm not I'm not sweating that
most of them only have two views okay
we're gonna talk about while we're
getting rid of all this I think you know
we'll leave these comparison operator
comments here but basically we're gonna
talk about in this episode episode four
while do-while and for loops because
these are all sort of similar and sort
of serve a very similar purpose and
we're gonna talk about things like okay
let's just get into it so let me let me
think of a little scenario where I could
show you these okay a while loop looks
like this a do-while loop looks like
this a for loop looks like this well not
wait for it it's a spider you see the
spider check that out okay so I will
explain all these a while loop it's sort
of in the same way that what we talked
about last episode where it checks in
these parentheses before going into the
block it does that to a while loop we'll
check some sort of thing here and see if
it returns two if it returns true it
loops and as long as the thing in these
parentheses is true it keeps looping so
if you just put a number in here it'll
always be true and this will loop
indefinitely so just this right here
will never finish running because it
will be stuck in this loop forever let
me show you main go ahead and compile it
and whoa I didn't save there we go oh it
wants an expression before or this
do-while and there's nothing there let's
comment this out for the moment it's
coming out this - it might throw some
weird error since it's not filled out
either let's just look at this while
loop and I'm talking about this infinite
thing so we'll go ahead and run what we
compile and we'll just sit here forever
nothing whatever happened
it'll just it's actually in this loop
and just running it and definitely
because 12 is not 0 so it's always true
ok so the point of this is you usually
have what's called a guard so you might
have something like a boolean called
I don't know is running you see this
very commonly in games so every video
game you've ever played has a while loop
called the game loop and it is basically
one of these that runs until you quit so
it'll have a flag that says something
like is running or quit it hasn't quit
something like that so as long as this
is true it'll run and within the loop
you have all the stuff your game does so
it's something like that but you want to
have some scenario in here where is
running turns to false and the game
exits or the game quits so that didn't
last very long what we can do here is
have a little fun and create a little
logic scenario so you do have to declare
the variable that you're gonna check
before the while loop somewhere it has
to know about it why that mean might
seem obvious it might not always be that
obvious when you're new so say we have
an integer called
number of loops and we set that to 10th
and maybe in here we have a sea out and
we say x ran
and then will spit out a times R and
variable which you have to create
somewhere we'll do it up here or I can
do I can show you a little something
called a static variable static times Oh
needs to be an integer or something
static int times R and now I will
explain
static skews I've never talked about
them in this series before there's kind
of a lot to them but I'll show you I'll
talk about just kind of the main stuff
I'll start it out at zero I actually
will start it out at one so the first
time it runs it will say x around 1 okay
so as static as you can see it's in this
block and as this loops again it
reenters the scope so normally if I have
if I had it just like this
it would recreate this variable and read
eclair with a 1 but if it's static that
means it sticks basically and it doesn't
recreate it doesn't destroy and recreate
so this will create the very first time
it runs but after that it's just gonna
stay there and this will allow us to
declare it with in this loop and not
have it read eclair but just will stick
with the same variable so it basically
prevents it from being created a bunch
of times and let's just keep the same
one now the other option is we could
just do this up here so it's not within
a loop and starting a new loop and
potentially read eclair in it and only
declares lonesome to me but if it's not
used anywhere else in the program only
in this loop it's often a good idea to
encapsulate its usage where it actually
is so hence why it might be a good idea
to do it here I'm gonna call this to run
and I'm gonna make this Const say we
don't ever want to change it so a
constant variable is no longer a
variable because it doesn't vary its
constant
so that way we can't change this any
attempt to change this will result in a
compiler error or a crash um the point
of that is just to keep your programming
consistent so you can't crash things on
your own okay so as this runs as long as
it's running we're gonna say times ran
so if you look at this how it is right
now it should just run one time and it's
gonna say it is running to false times
ran one but if we put a guard on this is
running another guard say first of all
we're gonna increment times ran after it
runs once so this plus plus just
increments it there's also a minus minus
which couldn't decrement in we're gonna
do a plus plus so after it spits this
out it's gonna say Times ran goes up one
so we're gonna split this up this is
kind of the end of the end of the while
loop update of the state and will say if
Times ran is greater than number of
loops to run then we'll set this to
false
please syntax there there we go
so now this will run until it's it's
greater than this now another thing we
could do is I think we could put the
plus plus right here
oddly enough and it being in front is
it's going to increment it before the
check if I put it after it would
increment after the check so that's just
another weird little syntax thing you
doin let's check it out we should get up
to ten oops let me compile first and yep
there we go so I haven't really talked
about this increment thing but yeah if
it's if the your increment things in
front it does it before going forward
with the operation if I do it over here
it'll do the check thing first and it
might I think it will actually get to
eleven if I do it this way let's let's
find out
oMG yeah
so that's the difference between these
this one does it after so if I only
wanted to go to ten I would do it like
that but that's a little weird to read
if you're new it might be just easier to
do the way I had it before or I just had
it on its own line but ultimately it
doesn't matter sometimes it's nice to
save space this to me makes perfect
sense all right so that's a while loop
and it has a guard of his running has a
little check to see if I should exit or
not it's also worth noting that it'll
just never enter the loop if this is
false there did an inner loop it's a
skip run past it so there can be
scenarios where you want it to go into
the loop at least once no matter what
and that's the point of the do-while
loop which you could also use it as a
game load and I will talk briefly about
that so let's let's comment out that
while loop and let's get into this
do-while loop and I'll talk a little bit
about how that works so no matter what
it goes into this once let's let's grab
this we'll use the same sort of stuff
uncomment there and yeah we'll make our
times ran we'll say times ran again and
then we can increment it except the is
running is now set o is now checked at
the end and once it executes once it
essentially functions like a while loop
it's just that first one that matters so
even if is running is false
it's still gonna run once check this out
you know still ran once even though is
running is false so that's the point
that and we could say and here just to
even so it could even start as false
okay so if I put a bracket here I don't
know what the autocomplete thing is but
you've thrown me off there so if it
doesn't say that the false we could say
since it's a true just to make sure it's
still running in case it started out as
false and in this case we would get to
our ten loops so that's how do while
works and the difference there now let's
talk about for loops sort of another
form of while loops you can actually
make this infinite or go work very
similar to a while loop if you want but
generally how people use this see the
little spider calls in the eyes off are
the things I love it okay usually on the
first one you either declare or set a
variable and it stays within this scope
the very what you see the most office
often office often is int I equals 0
that's usually how people do this I mean
you start out with the integer of IDEs
then it's zero and the second one is the
guard it's the same as this condition
right here basically and usually people
have the limit of their loop like until
until I is or while I is less than
number of loops to run we use that again
so it'll be ten what we could go change
it at any point to whatever we want I'll
do 20 just for fun and over here is the
update after every run so this standard
here is I plus plus so it increments and
then we could put the let's see I guess
all we really need in this case is this
C out and if we run this well times ran
is no longer being used here so instead
we're using high so we'll put an eye
there and I is going to start out as
zero so it's gonna say zero to start we
can put it change it to a 1 here to make
it properly say 1 because times I ran
zeros not actually correct it's it's
gonna be 1 so there we go 1 to 19 and
since this is less 10
we make it less than or equal to it'll
go to 20 you know some people do things
like I don't know say you definitely
want it to start at zero and I'll see
that and you want it to say the right
number so that you might say a plus one
here every time and that way you still
get an accurate read out oh let me
compile okay press up a bunch of times
there we go and there we go we get a
more accurate readout
okay well that's those loops and if you
have any questions leave them below
don't forget to leave a like subscribe
the channel if you'd like to learn more
about C++ and see more random tutorials
from me and keep the real keep coding
remember I believe C in the next episode